STEVE: THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS OPENING CIVIL
RIGHTS INVESTIGATIONS INTO THOSE
FIVE REPUBLICAN-LED STATES
THAT BANNED OR  LIMITED MASK
REQUIREMENTS IN SCHOOLS,
INCLUDING UTAH, OKLAHOMA, IOWA,
TENNESSEE, AND SOUTH CAROLINA,
THE EDUCATION SECRETARY IS
SAYING "STATE BANS ON UNIVERSE
UNIVERSAL INDOOR MASKING ARE
PUTTING THEIR CHILDREN AT RISK
AND PREVENTING THEM FROM
ACCESSING IN-PERSON LEARNING
EQUALLY.
IT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE THAT
STATE LEADERS ARE PUTTING
POLITICS OVER THE HEALTH AND
EDUCATION OF THE STUDENTS."
ALL RIGHT FOR CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS , LET'S BRING IN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY AND FORMER HISTORY
TEACHER, AND HE NEVER LETS US
FORGET THAT, LEO TERRELL.
LEO, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> [LAUGHTER]
STEVE, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I COULDN'T SLEEP LAST NIGHT.
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THIS ,
BECAUSE OF THE JUST OUTRAGEOUS
ACCUSATION THAT THE SECRETARY OF
EDUCATION IS MAKING.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR, STEVE.
THERE IS NO CIVIL RIGHTS
VIOLATION.
THERE'S NO VIOLATION THE
REHABILITATION ACT OR  THE
AMERICAN DISABILITY ACT.
THIS IS A POLITICAL WITCH HUNT
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TRY
TO IMPOSE FEDERAL MANDATES ON
STATES, REGARDING MASKING KIDS.
STEVE, WHERE'S THE MEDICAL
EVIDENCE THAT ANY KID WHO HAS A
DISABILITY IS BEING DENIED A
QUALITY EDUCATION?
IT'S STRICTLY POLITICAL.
IT'S A BACK DOORWAY TO IMPOSE
MASK MANDATES BY JOE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: WELL, THE DEPARTMENT OF
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS ANNOUNCED
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND THEN THEY
SAY THOSE STATES HAVE ISSUED
VARYING PROHIBITIONS ON MASK
REQUIREMENTS WHICH THE OFFICE
SAYS COULD PREVENT SOME STUDENTS
FROM SAFELY ATTENDING SCHOOL,
AND ALSO IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
YOU KNOW, LEO, I WAS TALKING TO
SOMEBODY WHO LIVES ACROSS THE
STREET FROM ME YESTERDAY.
SHE'S BEEN GOING TO THE TOWN
MEETINGS REGARDING GETTING KIDS
BACK-TO-SCHOOL IN ABOUT A WEEK,
AND OUR TOWN IS SPLIT RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE.
HALF THE PARENTS WANT THE KIDS
IN MASKS, HALF THE PARENTS DON'T
WANT THE KIDS IN MASKS AND SO
THEY ARE FIGURING IT OUT ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
ISN'T THAT THE WAY IT'S SUPPOSED
TO WORK?
>> YES, STEVE, AND HERE'S THE
THING ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS
THE PANDEMIC TO CONTINUE.
THEY WANT FEDERAL CONTROL.
IT'S A DEPENDENCY AND A POWER
ARGUMENT.
THIS SHOULD BE HANDLED ON THE
SCHOOL LEVEL ON THE DISTRICT
LEVEL AND STEVE HERE IS THE PART
SO OBVIOUS.
IF THERE WAS A DISABILITY
VIOLATION, DO YOU SEE ANY OF
THESE FAMILIES IN THESE LOCAL
DISTRICTS, IN THESE REPUBLICAN
STATES MAKING THIS ALLEGATION?
THIS IS A GAME.
THEY ARE USING THE PANDEMIC AS
AN  EXCUSE TO IMPOSE POWER.
THERE IS NO, I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS IS IN MY WHEEL HOUSE,
MIGUEL CARDONAS ACCUSATION OR
INVESTIGATION IS A FRAUD
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ADA VIOLATION
ONE LAST POINT.
IT MAKES THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
KIDS THAT WANT TO OR  WHO
ARE DISABLED MUST WEAR A MASK OR
ALTERNATIVELY EVERYONE ELSE
HAS TO WEAR A MASK.
WHERE IS THE MEDICAL EVIDENCE?
I SUBMIT TO YOU THERE ISN'T ANY.
STEVE: WELL, AND THE CDC HASN'T
LOOKED AT KIDS IN MASKS BECAUSE
MAYBE THEY DON'T WANT TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW EFFECTIVE THEY ARE,
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
>> EXACTLY, STEVE.
I'M TELLING YOU I WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THIS , BECAUSE THIS
IS WHAT FOX HIRED ME FOR.
I'M A CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
THERE IS NO ADA VIOLATION.
THERE'S NONE.
THIS IS A POLITICAL STUNT BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO TRY
TO GO BACK DOOR TO IMPOSE
FEDERAL MANDATE OF MASKING.
BRING ON DR. NICOLE AND THE
OTHER DOCTORS WE HAVE HERE.
THERE'S NONE.
THERE IS NO JUSTIFICATION.
ADA IS NOT IN PLIGHT.
STEVE: LEO THAT'S WHY WE WOK